I have to see him.
I'll do whatever it takes!
Come on in.
We have a newcomer, you guys.
I...
So... this is Cat Island?
And everyone in this bar used to be human?
That's right.
You want to be a cat too?
You must have had an awful time
as a human being!
Humans are horrible, aren't they?
Well, that's a little extreme.
-Hey, you.
-Yes?
If you want to go back to being a human,
you should leave as soon as possible.
But I can't talk to humans as a cat.
I need to tell someone how I really feel.
-So...
-Why are you still here then?
Once the Mask Seller takes your lifespan,
you'll be stuck here forever.
You won't be able to go back
to being a human.
That... would be a problem.
I have a question.
Don't you regret turning into a cat?
I do, but what's the point
of dwelling on it?
It just makes it more depressing.
We ran away.
All of us here chose to run
from our problems.
That's right.
Take me, for example.
I ran from my responsibilities
as a mother.
I was having doubts. Was I giving
my children the love they deserved?
I began to feel like they knew
I wasn't up to the task.
So I ran away.
Me too.
I didn't know how to love or be loved.
My insecurities suffocated me,
and I had to escape.
We've come to terms with our decisions.
But you still have your life ahead of you.
Tell your special someone
how you really feel.
I know you can do it!
-Thanks!
-Too bad, so sad!
What?
Hinode isn't in the human realm.
-What?
-I locked him in my shop.
What? You did that to Hinode? Why?
He came here to look for you.
What? You're lying.
Hinode doesn't even know I'm Taro.
The cat that has your face...
Kinako, was it?
She was with him,
so he probably heard from her.
Kinako was with him?
Yes, siree!
Why couldn't they wait a little longer?
You'll turn into a real cat soon enough.
Hinode was looking for me? Why?
We must not let them derail our plans.
Let's hurry and get going
to the Promised Place now.
Stop it.
She's still a kid.
Children have longer lifespans.
Much longer than you!
I want her lifespan!
We have to save this Hinode.
Let's go to his shop.
Yes. Thank you. All of you!
-Hurry!
-Okay!